des débats autour de la question des
transports notamment lors de ce dernier
conseil d'agglomération avant les
vacances la délibération portant sur le
projet de renfort de plusieurs lignes
d'autocars a été l'occasion d'aborder la
stratégie globale de couverture du
territoire avec des points de vue
différents sur les lignes les moins
fréquentées
l'appréciation de l'organisation des
transports depuis longtemps et faites de
manière trop technocratique par la
région que ce soit ile-de-france
mobilité ou avant le stif un peu importe
par l'autorité que responsable des
transports une autorité organisatrice de
transport
elle doit se préoccuper de la desserte
de tous les quartiers partout et même et
contiennent faible fréquentation d'une
ligne qui existent elles existent on
doit s'en préoccuper
quand il y a dix fois plus de personnes
sur un site bah oui et qui a moins de
trente personnes sur un autre trajet oui
on diminue le nombre de deux
de passage sur le site houiller 30
personnes et on va l'augmenter par jour
on imaginer et on le demande bien sûr
sur là où il ya plus de 1000 personnes
bien sûr pour donner plus
1 un espace où il ya plus d'activité bah
oui il faut enlever ailleurs parce
qu'aujourd'hui on en a pas on doit
travailler à l'intérieur d'un cercle
fermé de financièrement on a pu ces
pylônes en époque 1 concrètement dès le
mois de septembre cette course par jour
seront ajoutées sur la ligne 475,6 pour
la ligne 39 12 plus globalement la
question des déplacements sera étudiée
dans le cadre du projet de territoire un
projet en partie présenté lors de cette
même séance et qui entend établir deux
priorités emploi et économie de demain
et dynamisation du cadre de vie de ce
conseil d'agglomération l'on retiendra
aussi que le déficit de l'île de loisirs
reculent grâce à une diversité des
activités sur le site -6% par rapport à
2016 il s'établit à 836 1000 euros pris
en charge par l'agglomération et le
département on a été élu pour pour
diminuer la dette pour pour équilibrer
les comptes
en même temps et en même temps on peut
améliorer la qualité ça peut toujours
faire mieux avec moins
une autre bonne nouvelle après l'annoncé
par standard and poor's de l'attribution
de la note aa - à la gestion de saint
quentin en yvelines